hey Tommy it's me your uncle I'm not on
the bus I am the bus I know it's crazy
but I was dabbling with some dark magic
and I spilled a dudesy mug on my spells
and somehow I accidentally transferred
my soul into the school bus so now I'm
trapped in this bus and you're the only
person who can hear me I know how to get
back in my body but I'm gonna need your
help you have to drive me in a bus race
against the devil on Halloween if we win
I get to go back into my body if we lose
every human being on the planet will
turn into a bus so what do you say
Connie will you be my good job boner
I thought she was oh I've got a ways to
win
jeez I've got a race to win I didn't
watch Uncle bust dude